so liebe Leute wenn ihr ein Video sehen
wollt in dem Serda somunjo so richtig
ausrastet dann schaut jetzt das
Fragenlotto da beschreibt der nämlich
sehr plastisch eine Szene in der
ausgeflept ist und er sagt tatsächlich
aber er meint es nicht so ganz ehrlich
ich hasse Joko und KAS warum wieso
weshalb und wir tatsächlich zu Ihnen
steht jetzt im Fragenlotto bis dann
bleib
dran gut wir kommen zum Finale ah Finale
das ist wir hatten es gerade in der
nutzerfage schon das ist das Fragenlotto
die roten sind gemeine Fragen die Grünen
sind harmlose Fragen du kannst selber
wählenot rot rot rot okay hat jemand
schon harmlose Fragen gewählt ganz
selten komm eine grüne eine rote ja du
kannst wie du möchtest ja ein paar mehr
dann schon aber war mach mal ma dann gib
mir alle dann gib
mirb aber bei den Grünen ist auch eine
sehr
gemeine habt ihr das verpackt wie süß
war das deine Kollegin nein das war ich
so mit dem tackerbor wie schön das sit
sich dann da vorne habe ich gesessen
getackert geschnitten gefallt also
beantworte du bitte die Frage kannst du
auch nett sein für mich ja du kannst
nett sein hab ich festgestellt du warst
schon ein bisschen krabitzig im
Interview ja du hast geguckt bringe ich
ihn wirklich aus der Fassung aber das
war nett noch das war nett das war nett
doch doch do ich finde auch ich kann
nett sein ich muss nicht nett sein aber
ich kann du kannst aber sehr böse auch
sein ich kann auch böse sein ja
z.B hast du dich erschrocken bisschen
ich war F es war ich zehntel Sekunde
vorher habe ich damit gerechnet deswegen
bist du vielleicht der beste deutsche
Kabarettist vielleicht ist eine
Frechheit ähm nein ich versuche in dem
was ich mache der Beste zu sein sonst
würde ich es nicht machen und ob ich es
bin das entscheiden die Leute ich glaube
schon dass ich ganz gut bin also denke
ja nicht der beste Kabarettist ist auch
so kamarettis ja komm das ist aber immer
das falsche Wort hätte ich jetzt
komedien geschrieben hättest Du mich
gewirkt hier ja ja auch ja sowieso also
der Anlass D zu wken ist sehr nahliegend
der hat aber nichts mit deinen Fragen zu
tun sondern womit
Quatsch mit deiner impertinenten Art
nein Quatsch nicht weiß ich nicht ich
glaube nicht ob ich der Beste bin weß
nicht projizierst du mit deinen
Beleidigungen nicht deine Schwächen auf
andere was für eine
psychoanalytische Frage die irgendetwas
in mir aufdecken will ja habe ich denn
Schwächen ich habe sicher
Schwächen und ob ich die auf andere
projizeren
muss und ob ich das mit Beleidigung
mache nein nein die Antwort ist einfach
chen nein also wenn du wo bist und
benennst diese Leute in möglichst
unflätiger Art und Weise hat das nichts
mit dir zu tun sondern nur mit ich sag's
jetzt nicht wieder aber ween man man
merkt ja das lächel wie du grinst wenn
du wenn du diese Irritation im Publikum
merkst was sagt da aber was ist daran
dann Schwäche also wo ist die Schwäche
meine Schwäche deine Schwäche ist dass
du das brauchst ah ich geil mich daran
auf dass die ach so genau nee ne das ist
nicht so ne also mir bringt das
natürlich eine gewisse
Satisfaktion zu sehen dass Leute sich
irritieren lassen weil es natürlich auch
eine Interaktion ist und ich merke hey
da ist was aufgegangen aber ich brauche
das nicht um zu funktionieren das ist
ganz wichtig okay woher nimmst du deine
Schlagfertigkeit das ist Erfahrung also
wenn du zehn Mal Interviews geführt hast
und die erste Frage ist wie ist die Lage
dann weißt du mindestens beim neunten
Mal was du sagst aber komm wie ist die
Lage wird eigentlich nie gefragt kein
Journalist die versuchen ja immer
möglichst entweder eine möglichst
intellektuelle Frage zu stellen ja oder
eine wo sie denken dass ihr Publikum nee
natürlich nicht die gleiche Frage aber
mit einer Frage die standardisiert ist
fangen viele an neulich bei Visa der
bezaubernden Visa muss ich sagen die
hatte auch so eine Standardfrage am
Anfang die dann schon so weit weg war
von dem was Sie vielleicht wirklich
wissen wollte dass man als
Außenstehender erstmal denkt H wie ist
die Lage fragt man das auch wie ist die
Lage doch doch doch doch du gehst so in
Kiosk kaufst zwei Flaschen Bier da Dach
wie ist die
Lage schnau Alter bei mir in Fleisch und
Blut über gegangen du sagst wirklich wie
ist die Lage ja nicht immer aber auch
deiner Frau du kommst so nach dem
Interview kommst nach Hause Schatz wie
ist die Lage du geiler [__] sag die
Leute rufen mich an ich sehe W auf dem
Display ist und ich die sagen und ich
sage sofort wie ist die
Lage f
warum bist du so kolerisch das ist eine
Frage die
ist schnell zu beantworten ist eine
Unterstellung erstmal bist du kolerisch
bist du gar nicht nein gar nicht es gibt
wenn ich Regie mache Momente wo ich
total ausraste aber dann ist die
Situation auch zum Ausrasten ich
erinnere mich an eine viele meiner
Kollegen erzählen das heute noch wir
haben damals Dracula gemacht ich habe
das inszeniert und eine Szene war so
dass vier Statisten eine Tischdecke
halten mussten und vier andere Statisten
in in einer ineinander übergehenden
Bewegung besteckt Teller und Gläser auf
den Tisch zu stellen hatten und ich habe
als Regisseur gesagt es ist mir alles
egal die Becher können auf dem Boden
fallen die Tischdecke kann reißen ihr
dürft nur eins nicht machen privat sagen
oh der Teller ist mir
runtergefallen okay und die Generalprobe
war nachts um 2 Uhr wir waren in Verzug
und das ganze Ding war durch das war
fast die letzte Szene alles stand dann
kippt so ein Becher auf die Seite und
und einer der Statisten sagt oh der
Bcher so
ich das hat eine Stunde gedauert bis ich
wieder runtergekommen ab dann bist du
doch ein bisschen cholerisch zu weil
also wenn man sich dementsprechend
benimmt bin ich auch
cholerisch hast du eigentlich alles nein
eigentlich nur Joko und KAS hast du die
nein nein nein nein nein nein ich mag
die beiden sie haben zwar was von dem
leptosom und ein pügniker was ist denn
ein leptosom und pügniker pgnik was
Kleines ne ja Rudolf Steiner der so
leichtte dem unterstellt man ja auch so
ein bisschen faschistoide Züge der hat
Menschen kategorisiert nach
nach Stereotypen also nach Grundformen
von körperlich körperlichen Merkmalen
und der leptosom ist so glaube ich der
langewachsene genau und der pügniker ist
so der mit dem dicken Bauch oder aber
auch lollek und bollek wahlweise das ist
ein Spiel zwischen uns wir necken uns
weil wir uns lieben ich finde die beiden
grandios ein bisschen inflationär gerade
im Fernsehen aber sie haben es auch
verdient so viel wie die auf die
Schnauze bekommen haben ist nicht ein
Philosoph an dir verloren gegangen nö
ich lebe ja
noch und sitze hier vor dir und
philosophiere sehr schön man muss nicht
immer etwas sein man kann auch von allem
etwas sein kann man das ja manchmal
ergibt das große auch das kleine und das
kleine das große also da sind viele
Einzelteile auch etwas was ich
zusammenfügen kann es gibt eine starke
Tendenz dazu Menschen zu kategorisieren
zu verereinfach aber sich selber auch zu
kategorisieren meine Frage wä jetzt muss
man da nicht ein Überblick haben nein
das das war eben das was ich auch
erzählen wollte ich bin dankbar für
dieses Geschenk dass ich
unterschiedliche Talente habe und ich
habe es mir zur Aufgabe gemacht im
meinem Leben jede Facette meiner Talente
seit es geht auszu auszuleben
auszutragen und vielleicht auch zu
zeigen wenn sie gut genug sind bist du
glücklich dass du es kannst und auch
davon leben kannst ich bin ein sehr
glücklicher Mensch ja erstens weil ich
das kann und weil die Kunst mich sehr
befriedigt und auch weil ich tatsächlich
ja das große Glück habe viele
Katastrophen gut überstanden zu haben
manche gar nicht erlebt zu haben das
macht mich aber hoffentlich nicht
unempfindlich für die Katastrophen die
andere Menschen erleben okay vielen dank
danke auch Jo und wer jetzt ein
Fragenlotto sehen möchte inem es einen
tatsächlichen
Wutausbruch gibt der sollte sich das mit
djc ansehen außerdem nicht von
schlechten Eltern das mit MoTrip und dem
Titel sei kein Hater was er damit meint
jetzt angucken oder das franklotto mit
dem Grafen der darüber erzählte warum er
seinen wahren Namen nicht preis gibt
jetzt habt ihr Zeit hier unten drauf zu
klicken und jetzt sage ich tschüss
tschüss